hi
and welcome to the anthos deep dive
session part
two my name is dan cerulli and i'm a
product manager at google cloud
and hi i'm tony pajals i'm a developer
advocate at google cloud
and we're going to walk you through uh
the second part of the deep dive
on anthos i'm going to start with a
little bit of a level set to make sure
that you're clear on what the
different components are within anthos
and why they exist
and then i'm going to spend some time
deep diving on
antho service mesh and tony is going to
spend some time on cloud run for anthos
but first anthos itself anthos is an
application modernization platform it's
a platform that lets you
write applications and run them anywhere
on google cloud in your own premises
or on other clouds even at the edge in
places like
retail facilities or warehouses it's a
software-based solution that is aimed at
solving the problem of
how difficult it is to run things in
different places right now
it's there to give you consistency
across the different locations you're
going to have to deploy
in order to make your developers and
your operators
more efficient at their jobs
one of the key things that anthos
enables you to do is to modernize in
place
moving to the cloud can be hard moving
from old
monolithic architectures to new ones can
be hard and if you try to do both of
those things at the same time
well that's doubly hard with anthos you
can modernize your application where you
are
still in your in your data center if
that's where you are and move to the
cloud later as
a second step it's a much easier process
to follow
when you do start running applications
in multiple locations
anthos gives you consistency it lets you
do things like
write policy about security and have
that policy be in effect regardless of
where the application is running
this gives your developers your
operators your security people
all consistency to run the application
the same way
no matter where it's running
one key factor for anthos is that it is
a 100
software based solution you don't need
to invest in new hardware for anthos it
runs on your existing hardware and at
its core
it's based on a trio of open source
projects we do container management uh
using anthos gke which is of course
based on
the popular kubernetes container
deployment system
the service mesh component is antho
service mesh which is based on
istio the popular open source service
mesh
and up at the top giving your developers
a great development experience is cloud
run for anthos
we also have a great marketplace for the
other things that you might want to run
other software databases etc and around
this whole thing we've got a very good
policy management system
that lets you manage policy across all
the different locations
and good operations tools so that the
people who are
running the software uh have the same
experience regardless of where it's
running
on google cloud in your own premises on
other clouds
or at the edge now let me talk a little
bit about
my favorite component in anthos antho
service mesh
and to talk about antho service mesh i
want to talk about a trend in our
industry
of moving away from monolithic
applications
why did we decide to move away from on
monoliths well actually that second
bullet to me is the big one
uh monoliths make it slow to innovate
when you have a hundred developers
working on
an application you're probably deploying
that application
maybe once a quarter maybe once every
six months
it's very difficult to test and and
release
when you're when you're deploying huge
applications
they're also very expensive to scale
because monoliths tend to run on
on specialized very expensive hardware
and buying multiple
instances of that can be very expensive
and operation is
is is typically a a very difficult
process
the move to microservices really
addresses a lot of these problems and
again
starting with innovation with
microservices you have small teams of
developers who are each deploying small
units of code
because they can deploy independently
they can ship a lot faster they can ship
features much much more frequently that
means you end up
shipping features to your customers a
lot more often
and you can scale them all independently
microservices are typically deployed in
containers
they're running on commodity hardware
and they scale independently
and finally you've got a great ecosystem
of tools around
operations that make operating these
easy
so what is a service mesh well a service
mesh helps you
solve some of those issues you'll have
as you decompose your application
a service mesh transparently and in a
language independent way
adds functionality into your network
calls
so that your developers don't have to
write a new
a bunch of new infrastructure to handle
those
it's a core component of anthos we offer
antho service mesh
as i said before this is based on istio
the most popular service mesh
application in open source today and
what does it do specifically
well there's three main things that you
get from a service mesh
first it gives you the ability to
understand the traffic between your
services
now that your monolith has broken up
into microservices you've got a lot of
components communicating with each other
and a service that mesh can make sure
that you are monitoring logging and
tracing
all of that traffic so you can
understand your application
second a service mesh gives you advanced
networking functionality to make it so
you can have operational agility
make it so you can safely roll out new
components
uh do locality-based load balancing if
you're running in multiple clusters
and finally a service mesh lets you
secure all of that traffic and ensure
that
everything is encrypted in transit and
you can write policy to dictate
who's allowed to communicate with whom
today
i'm going to focus on two key areas here
in understanding your application and
the ability to use some of these
advanced networking
capabilities and to do that we're going
to use some
chaos engineering and inject a little
chaos into our application
chaos engineering lets you test the
resiliency of your application
by seeing what happens when different
components
break antho service mesh in addition to
a lot of other things it can do
can allow you to inject chaos and what
i'm going to demonstrate
now is how we can inject some chaos to
see how our application behaves
if one of the components starts running
more slowly or
if one of the components starts failing
for this demonstration i'll be using an
e-commerce
application it was developed using
microservices so we can deploy
frequently and independently
as you can see it's a nice modern
application
with a bunch of services underneath
let's look and see what antho service
mesh can do to help us
understand this application and how
failures might
contribute to it
a service mesh is gathering all kinds of
information about our application
not just the telemetry that it's been
gathered but the
actual topology of the application
which services are communicating with
which
other services for i can see
every service in my application as well
as how they relate to every others
including how much traffic they're
sending to others this is some powerful
information
and for any of these services i can dive
in
and i can understand them even more
deeply
here i'm getting tons of information
about my front end of the application
this is the one the users actually hit
so it's the one i care the most about it
as with every other service that's
deployed in the mesh
i get great telemetry on it i can see
how much traffic this is serving i can
see things like what its error rates are
and how they change over time
as well as what its latencies are i can
do this on
many one of many time spans i can zoom
out a little bit and see how it's been
performing during the day
one of the great features about antho
service mesh is the ability to set
service level
objectives as i said this is really
important
especially on the front end for me to
assess the health of my application
i can see that this application is
currently healthy
and i've got an objective here that says
a
certain percentage 95 of my
requests should be fulfilled within 200
milliseconds
however earlier today you can see where
i injected
a little chaos in this system and i'm
going to show you how i did that
i used antho service mesh and its
use of the istio apis to inject a delay
in my service i've got a recommendation
service in here
it recommends new products to my uh
customers
and i said 10 of the time i want you to
add
a one mil one second delay to see what
the effect of that would be
on the system system seems to behave
pretty well
but let's look closely again at that
service level objective
i can see that i started failing that
objective some of the time
when i when i injected that chaos
and if i look at my error budget over
this time frame i can actually see it's
going down
relatively rapidly now the system isn't
telling me that i'm going to run out
today
in fact it thinks i'm going to make it
through the day but this does tell me as
the person running this service
i've got a dependency that i'm really uh
that is very critical for me
if the recommendation service were to
actually start performing like this
i would be close to and maybe even would
exceed
my slo and run out of error budget so
what am i going to do well first i would
tell the recommendations team
you should be setting your own sl loans
i need you to be returning faster
than one second so i want you to have a
stricter slo than that so you catch your
own errors
but second it tells me that i should
make sure that the front end
is resilient and in fact maybe can time
out if the recommendation service takes
too long
and those service mesh could help with
that as well now i'm going to talk about
a different sort of chaos
we can inject and that is failures
as we said before the service mesh is
in telling me exactly how my system is
related how many
services comprise it and how they relate
to each other
here you can see my front end actually
talks to a service called the cart
service
now the cart service is an important uh
service in my application people can't
see what they're buying if they if they
can't put things in the cart
however if that should fail at some
point i still want the system to be
resilient
so i'm going to use antho service mesh
to inject some chaos
i've got a file here called cart error
again it's using the open source
istio apis and it's saying hey in the
cart service
i want you 100 of the time to throw a
500.
i'm not going to have to redeploy the
application and i'm not going to have to
recode the application i'm just going to
tell the service mesh to start
returning these errors i've already made
this change and
i have made a commitment
and i can see all i need to do is push
this
and it will or commit this push it and
it will
take effect so
i'm going to inject some chaos here
and then i'm going to push this now my
system of record which is the
the source code repository has the new
policy
anthos config management is taking that
policy
and pushing it into each of my clusters
and as soon as they do i can see the
effects of that policy
so my application is still here and
running and
wow is that a catastrophic failure
now again the shopping cart service is
important
but this is not acceptable this is
telling me that i need to be
more resilient so now i'm going to have
to go to the rec the
front end application team and make sure
that they
are resilient to a
failure from the shopping cart
application
now i do want to say you saw that
injecting chaos
put some serious breakage in our
application i don't recommend you do
this in your production clusters at
least at first
try this in your dev clusters now uh i'd
like to turn it over
to tony who's going to talk about cloud
run for anthos
thanks dan so dan just did a really
great job of explaining the benefits of
microservice architecture
and what anthes does to help you manage
these
applications that you've deployed but
what can we do to improve that
experience for developers
so the metaphor here is i want to be
productive in my space i want to enjoy
my space but i don't
have to do all the work to create the
space and maintain it
so how can cloud run for anthos help us
with that
what we see here is that cloud run for
anthos is right here at the top of this
stack
meaning that it is focused on the
developer experience
and what can we do to improve that
developer experience we're going to get
to that
why would you choose cloud run for
anthos in a nutshell the idea is that
you're going to get all the benefits of
containerization
of your microservice applications but
without the overhead of managing
infrastructure and dealing with some of
the complexity that kubernetes
introduces when you work at the
kubernetes level for your applications
so looking here what we see
is a spectrum where you can deploy
applications directly
on prem as vms on-prem or in the cloud
and on the far right we have a fully
managed serverless experience
but for whatever reason that your org
has chosen anthos is because
likely because you need to run certain
applications that don't fit the
serverless model
you've got infrastructure that you do
have to manage but for those
applications that could benefit from the
serverless approach
you can leverage cloud run for anthos
without having to worry about the
infrastructure for those applications
that you deploy
cloud run for anthos leverages k native
which is built on top of kubernetes
and therefore your operators and
everybody in your environment familiar
with kubernetes already
gets to leverage that but from the
developer experience
you're going to be able to deploy your
applications using a much more
simplified
model and i'm going to demonstrate
exactly what that means
because i'm going to take the same app
that dan was demonstrating
and i'm going to migrate it to cloud run
for anthos
all right let's dive in this is the repo
for the microservices demo app
that's launched as part of the antho
sample deployment that dan used
it's a fairly high fidelity example of a
sophisticated microservices application
built for a fictional enterprise
it's published as an ecommerce website
called online boutique
and architecturally it's composed of
10 microservices that communicate over
grpc
and it's got a data store that we've
simulated with redis
and also we've added a load generator so
that we can simulate
a bunch of users sending traffic to the
public front end
it's typically deployed as a kubernetes
plus istio application as dan previously
demonstrated
so what i'm going to show you is how
with just
some configuration changes you can take
advantage of a simplified serverless
model and seamlessly
integrate this with existing workloads
running on your kubernetes clusters
and that's the main point i'm going to
be driving here today so
in other words this demo isn't going to
be about all the benefits of
of serverless per se there's already a
ton of content about that
um more importantly i want to show you
how cloud run for anthos makes it easy
for your ops teams to provide you with
the benefits of serverless coexisting
seamlessly in your kubernetes
environments this will
leverage your operators expertise along
with the benefits of using anthos
our application modernization platform
and so with cloud run for anthos
you're going to get to exploit the best
developer deployment model
that makes the most sense for each
service that you build and deploy
and just to take a look uh you know here
are
here are the kubernetes manifests
and the istio manifests
and so what we're going to do
is what you'll want to do is fork
my repo here cloud run for anthos labs
and
and go to this sample right here and
here all the instructions
are provided so everything that i'm
going to show you can be found in this
repo including a script that you're
going to need well that you can use for
creating a kubernetes cluster with gke
and if you want to create a um if you
want to create a cluster
using the web console just remember to
make sure that you
check the box enable cloud run for
anthos for the cluster
this uh this line here basically is the
part that
ensures that our cluster is going to be
um is going to have the full cloud run
for antho support enabled
now i have already done this
to say sometimes so let's go to
our kubernetes
engine dashboard and confirm
i've got cluster one here it's this is
just a
just a kubernetes uh cluster running on
gke
uh and this is what was installed um
with the cluster with the cloud run
support enabled
uh the only services running on it right
now
let me sort here by namespace so within
the gke connect namespace what we're
going to see is
support for cloud run error reporting
and logging to stackdriver
control plane component uh
for configuring our cluster local
gateway for all the
traffic and you know microservice to
microservice internal traffic
as well as our public ingress to the
cluster uh and these last
four um services are all
uh are all required to provide that
serverless foundation
on top of kubernetes that makes cloud
run for amthos work
so now that we've got a cluster we're
going to want to deploy our application
let's take a look at the configuration
changes that we need to make this
work with cloud run for anthos quick
refresher
here's the architecture of our
application once again
i want to point out that the load
generator is a long-running service
that is intended to send traffic
as long as the service is running and
until it's terminated
so as a long-running service this is not
a good candidate
for running under running as a
serverless
app and therefore this is going to be
deployed as a standard kubernetes
service
so the same thing is true for redis
which
is also not a good candidate for
servlets because
it requires an attached volume and
and this isn't consistent with the goals
of running
as a k-native service under the under
the hood for auto-scaling purposes it's
not a good fit for the service
serverless model so this is a
long-running service and this is a
stateful service
these are both going to be deployed
as normal you know as normal kubernetes
deployments the rest of these will be
deployed
as serverless apps
so what we're going to look at is the
delta
between the original kubernetes manifest
in this repo and the
manifest that i have added for you
in this repo under the k native
directory
and what i'm going to do actually is i'm
going to switch over to my editor
um because i want to give you a little
bit of an overview
about what changes before i actually
drill into the details
so for one thing k-native offers a
simplified
uh configuration abstraction there's a
single service here
compared to the need for two different
configurations a service and a
deployment under kubernetes
and because of that you don't need all
these selectors and and labels to
correlate the two configurations
you also don't need to predetermine the
the number of
of replicas you're going to need in
anticipation of of load and
availability requirements you can take
advantage of the fact that k native
provides auto scaling
out of the box you can still configure
minimum and maximum limits if you want
to but you don't
again you don't have to anticipate that
load
and if you only have a single container
in your service you don't even need to
give the container a name
minor simplifications but when you look
at all of these in
aggregate you what you'll find is that
k-native offers a very nice
simplified configuration abstraction for
your service resources
so now let's uh dive into the actual
configuration in more detail
um here under the k native
v1 directory let's open up this services
yaml file
um and actually the first one that i
want to start with
i'll start with the front end since
that's the logical
entry point for the application anyway
what we see here the so the front-end
services expose the internet it serves
the web user interface and it
communicates with
uh various back-end services what you'll
see here
um obviously the first two lines
declaring that this is a a service
resource using the k native serving api
we've we've provided a name and metadata
that name needs to be unique within the
namespace there's no namespace
that we specified here so the default is
default
there's only one container provided here
we only need one container for this
service so there is no name
for it the front end service expects
environment variables with
dns name colon port values be set for
each of the backend services that it
will send requests to
so note also that all of these services
are in the default name space as well as
indicated by their dns names
the kubernetes compute resource
requirements for the container
are specified here and at least 10
percent of a vcpu
limited to 20 and at least uh 64
megabytes
uh mebabytes to start with
and a limit of double that
since the front end service listens
on the port identified at runtime with
the port invite environment
variable that is automatically set by k
native there's no need to specify a
container port value here
as some of the other services will that
we'll see in a moment
the default the default for the port is
8080 but it's a good practice for a
k-native service to get the value
of that port environment variable anyway
which this app does
so now now that we've covered that let's
let's
let's move on let's go to the ad service
so the front end fetches short text
advertisements to display from ad
service by sending a list of important
keywords
from the current page describing context
there's
important things note here just two
things in addition to the name
there is metadata that is used to
configure the services visibility as
cluster local
and this means that there's no public
access to the ad service it's a
private cluster local only service that
is
accessible from within the cluster
the container port is set to 8080 and
and although that's actually the default
because we need to provide
this and i'll explain this in a moment
we got to provide the full configuration
so
we do have to specify container port the
reason why we're providing name
is this is a specific name that
indicates
uh that we're going to be communicating
with uh grpc
or you know technically this is uh http
2
over tcp that's what the h2c stands for
um if this isn't provided then the
default of
under k native would be http one
uh let's see moving on cart service
okay so this provides the shopping cart
functionality for the app
uh the configuration should start
looking
pretty familiar by now there's only a
couple things we need to note here
the app does take a port option this
this minus p and we get the value from
the port environment variable that's set
by k native
it's listening on 8080 and again this is
a grpc
service http 2 over
tcp a couple of other environment
variables getting set here
and
um yeah and basically that's it
and let's see checkout service
uh checkout service is used to purchase
um items that the customer has added to
their cart
and like the front end and the cart
service that we just saw the checkout
services
checkout service uses environment
variables to get the addresses to use
for its
back-end back-ends that it communicates
with and that's
that's it here currency service is used
to convert currencies to display price
and here we can see that it actually
listens on a specific port 7000 so
this would need to be specified anyway
even if we weren't
um using grpc which we are
email service sends ordering and payment
info uh confirmation after purchase
and it's already been mentioned but the
only reason again for this specific
port even though it's the default is
because again this is a grpc these are
all these services are going to be grpc
except for the front end
cover the front end payment service
is used to make purchases at checkout
there's nothing
really new to explain about this product
catalog service is used to convert
currencies
when displaying price and
again it should look familiar nothing
new to explain here
service is used to make similar product
recommendations while browsing
and nothing need explained here and the
shipping service
which is used to purchase products which
is used to ship your purchase products
and there's nothing new to explain there
so this is this is all we had to do to
take our
kubernetes manifest it was basically
about what we stripped out
um did have to add some things
we had to add labels that that
constrained our visibility
and had to
provide these uh these hints as to
the type of traffic that we want
and that's it so now let's just
take a look at deploying the app um
i'll go ahead and start up a couple of
watches for our kubernetes deployment
and also around the case service
resource that just gives us another
perspective on deploying these services
i'll want to deploy
our back end for redis
remembering that this was a stateful
service with a
volume attached so this is just a normal
kubernetes deployment
and then i'm going to deploy the app
itself
and for now i'm going to deploy the
second version of the app go to the repo
check out the lab to see uh what it
means to have scaling to zero
configured and what it means for auto
scaling up in the v3
version but this will just be the v2
version where i've set
minimum scale to one so that services
never actually scale to zero
because for these services for the
website we're going to expect a
responsive user interface so
it's this is a nice thing to be able to
do but scaling to zero is normally the
default
that's also great for services that
don't need to
run all the time and consume compute
resources
for what you're getting billed now that
the app
is running i can
curl it so let's see to do that i'm
going to need to know the gateway ip
it's in the gke system namespace
for istio ingress and there's the ip
i'll also need to know
the um
the dns name for the for the route for
the front end
and what we'll see here is actually by
default the domain would have been
example.com
i already provided a custom mapping
just another configuration that you
apply
i took this basic uh template
and i configured it for a domain that i
controlled tonypregels.com
so that's what we're seeing right there
if i curl it
this request is going to go to the
ingress gateway
and it needs to know which to which
service to send it and so with
curl i'm going to do that by providing a
host header
it's our front-end service and the
default namespace
it would by default be example.com but
in this case since i provided a custom
domain mapping
it's tonyprojeals.com and here is the ip
that we're going to send that to
there you go we can see that a page
responded we can also also do this in
the browser
now if i send it to the ip address
obviously i can't send it to example.com
since that's not my domain i can't
configure records for it
if i send it to the ip address i need to
do something similar
like we just did um here when we curled
it i need to supply that um
that host header so you can use the mod
header chrome extension
specify your host header apply some
filter pattern so it doesn't apply to
every other
website that you go to
and there you go this is great for local
testing until you go through the trouble
of actually configuring that custom
domain
but you can test i can also
since i did configure it for my domain i
can also take advantage of the uh
automatic uh certificate for https
support
and there you go i'm at the top level
tonypizzas.com here's the application
if you've never seen it before it's a
simple
online shopping experience for each one
of these items i can
drill in i can see that the
recommendation service is providing
other products that are similar
i can see ads i refresh this page some
stuff will update add stuff to the cart
place your order off you go
last thing i want to do real quick is i
want to go over to the
cloud run dashboard
and our console there's all the services
running for each one of these services
you can
get access to its performance resources
it's consuming
take a look at logs
even uh go over directly to the
stackdriver page
under ops logging console
and get access to a ton of information
about um
how things are doing as well as take a
look again at the logs but with control
over the
how you want to filter what you want to
know
let's see my container logs
which are in the default name space
for my main containers
and maybe i want to watch them streaming
okay so let's go back here
to the repo
this is where you want to go there's a
lab these are all the steps to be able
to get through this lab
including uh checking out all the
out-of-scaling stuff that i didn't
demonstrate
scaling to zero and scaling up and um
and then finally cleaning up when you're
all done
i hope what i did demonstrate though is
that
with cloud run for anthos you can
definitely take advantage of your
kubernetes knowledge
your existing kubernetes clusters and
seamlessly coexist
with your kubernetes workloads and that
to me is the
biggest value proposition of cloud run
for anthos that in the fact that your
developers get to exploit
the serverless programming model that
will
accelerate their development so thanks a
lot and
back to you dan thanks tony that was
amazing i bet after watching two of
these deep dives you're ready to try
anthos for yourself uh
great news we're ready for you to try
that just go to goo
dot gle slash trianthos that's
goo dot goal slash trianthos and we've
got a
a fully hosted uh hands-on trial it'll
spin up a cluster where you can
experiment with all of these features
yourselves
thanks very much for your time